en le gouvernement voulait qu'il soit
détenu et jugé sur place en syrie ou en
irak
c'est donc le désengagement des
etats-unis en syrie qui oblige à changer
de position explique christophe castaner
car sinon sylvia discret ce que ford
s'évaporer dans la nature on écoute le
ministre de l'intérieur il était
l'invité de bfm ce matin
d'abord ce sont des français aouidat des
jihadistes vous savez que les américains
se désengage de syrie non mais oui mais
c'est important d'avoir sans tête
il ya actuellement des gens qui sont en
prison et qui sont tenus parce que les
américains sont là et qu'ils vont être
libérés ils vont être libérés ils vont
vouloir venir en france
ils vont vouloir revenir en france ce
que je souhaite moi c'est que tout ce
qui reviendrait en france soit
immédiatement mis yvan la main de la
justice avant de parler du fond olivier
duhamel
la phrase qu'on a entendu du début de
christophe castaner qui dit ce sont des
français avant des djihadistes
maladresse non c'est une réalité sont
des principes de droit
vous pouvez commettre les pires crimes
de la terre vous êtes toujours
ressortissants nationale d'une autre
pays sauf si on vous a déchu de la
nationalité donc vous êtes toujours
français ce qui implique d'une part que
quelles que soient les crimes
inacceptables horrible atroce que vous
avez commis d'une part si vous êtes à
l'étranger votre pays à devoir de
protection à votre égard et d'autre part
s'agissant de le jugement ils peuvent
être soit jugé sur place si les
conditions sont réunies parce que l'état
est compétent territorialement pour
juger ceux qui ont commis des crimes sur
son sol soit être jugé en france donc ce
que je vous dis là ce ne sont pas des
opinions ce sont les principes qui nous
gouvernent
une évidence ou une erreur politique de
commencer en disant sont des français
c'est une décision qui si elle est
avérée parce que il ya quand même
d'autres parce qu'on sent que le
secrétaire d'état laurent nunez commence
à dire mais non c'est pas si sûr on les
sent qu'ils sont très très embêté si
elle est adressée extrêmement lourde de
risque de danger parce que plus de 100
gars qui arriverait là qu'il faudrait
regrouper jugé faire craindre une sorte
de procès fleuve et c'est avec les
risques de surenchère sens là on parle
que des français parce qu'il ya derrière
aussi tous les ressortissants du maghreb
en fait l'algérie
un tunisien ou ou marocains qui risque
aussi une fois qu'ils auront ce qu'on
passait pas remplies de revenir ici
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
vertigineux en termes de risque
terroriste
jusqu'ici la position de la france qui
me paraissait bon sens était de dire il
faut qu'il soit jugé sur aucun ne
revient aucun ne revient pas on a dix
ans il y avait déjà eu un début de
polémique
les enfants enfants il est très bon les
enfants et la lmr on peut les faire
revenir donc ça c'est ça avait déjà fait
mais là ils étaient d'accord pour dire
non les djihadistes alors oui son
français bassement la foulée des choix
si le pc la raison de droit qui permet
de les laisser là où ils sont c'était
des choix faits les déchoir de leur
nationalité alors dans monsieur sur
cette fois on écoute puisque vous en
parlez valérie boyer députée l ère des
bouches du rhône elle en parlait cet
après midi à l'assemblée que ces
individus soient jugés en irak ou en
syrie où ils sont actuellement il ne
s'agit pas de crime ordinaire mais de
crimes contre l'humanité de crimes de
génocide pour lesquels les témoins
survivants de leurs exactions nous
disent que ceux qui parlaient français
étaient parmi les plus cruels vous
considérez les djihadistes comme
français mais nous les républicains
demandant depuis des années la défense
de leur nationalité les déchoir de leur
nationalité jeunes bourlanges ça résout
pas vraiment le problème où ça peut être
une solution ça résout sur le plan des
principes et juridique mais ça n'empêche
qu'ils rêvent de revenir un jour en
france
je crois qu'il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord sur l'expression de
questionnaire avant ils sont ils sont
français avant d'être tué dix c'est
simplement chronologique
ils sont français c'est leurs
caractéristiques juridiques et ils sont
livrés à des actes qui en font des
terroristes donc il faut pas c'est pas
du tout sur le même plan que ça doit et
demi deuxièmement le problème qu'on a
c'est qu'on ne veut pas moi je suis
incapable de savoir exactement ce qu'il
faut faire parce qu'il faut connaître la
situation sur le terrain autrement que
je ne la connaît mais on ne veut pas que
ces gens comme dit le ministre rapport
on ne veut pas que il échappe
et d'ailleurs ça va vous avez raison ça
va bien au delà des nationaux français
ça va ça concerne un ensemble de gens
qui sont effectivement situation
délicate ce que dit le gouvernement
français c'est que le retrait américain
fait peser sur leur maintien en
détention et
sur la réalité la certitude d'un
jugement dans le pays en question fait
peser des doutes des incertitudes assez
grande et qui vaut donc mieux les
rapatrier
je ne peux pas me prononcer là-dessus
mais je crois qu'il est effectivement
essentiel de ne pas les laisser partir
dans la nature
c'est très différent du problème posé
par les enfants parce que les enfants
des djihadistes et ils n'ont rien fait
si je puis dire
ce sont deux donc on ne va pas les
poursuivre dans la différence on va
essayer de les réintégrer
et c'est un travail extrêmement est
extrêmement difficile donc je crois que
le gouvernement fait ce qu'il peut moi
je trouverais comme madame boyer
d'ailleurs mais comme je crois tout le
monde je trouverai bien préférable que
tout ça soit réglé sur place sans qu'on
les fasse venir en france
est ce possible est ce qu'il y a des
capacités de sûreté pour les conserver
et des instances juridictionnelles à la
fois compétente est capable de
fonctionner apparemment ce que les
histoires d'hommes en français c'est que
tout ça c'est très douteux ça a été mal
anticipée cette affaire les bagues à ce
débat aberrant ils ne sont plus français
ils ont choisi l'état islamique s'il y
avait eu un état constitué ils auraient
ils ont non seulement nationalité
française ils sont allés se résoudrait
le choix ils ont rompu avec la france
ils ont trahi la france
ils ont souillé la france et s'il avait
pu tuer des français de leurs effets et
s'il y avait un état islamique
constitués ils seraient devenus des
citoyens de l'état islamique auquel cas
la france aurait dit bon ya pas de
mutualité
vous n'êtes plus français 2e 27 sont des
ressortissants français un traître c'est
un très bon oui mais eux je fais c'est
le budget français acceptons assumant
leurs responsabilités ils ont dessiné
qu'ils étaient plus français juste à des
ennemis la france ils veulent la
destruction de la france deuxièmement
nous aurions eu des terroristes qui
seraient venus accomplir des actes
criminels sur le territoire français est
le pays d'origine irak on va les
récupérer pour les juger chez nous il y
aura plus de garantie de droits mais il
est pas question
les terroristes étrangers qui commettent
des crimes aussi odieux et monstrueux
cela reste le territoire français on le
fait
vérité c'est pas qu'on n'est pas sûr
qu'il soit jugé c'est qu'on sait comment
ça va se finir
c'est à dire avec une rafale de
mitraillette parce qu'évidemment la
justice des 13 expéditives
mais comme il ya déjà en france pardon
des droits de l'hommisme sincère qui
disent quand même comme ce sont des
français
ça serait bien qu'ils bénéficient du
droit de la jeu de la juridiction
française et le est le leur marché
coincé là dedans et il ya un débat à
l'intérieur ma marche parce que pas de
pitié pour ces gens là et s'il vient en
france on aura quoi comme dossier
d'instruction
des éléments qui viendront de cyril
audirac et le juge dira écoutez faute de
preuves accablantes parce que c'est des
témoignages et ben il prend deux ans
avec sursis ou trois ans je ne sais pas
j'extrapole quelles sont les garanties
juridiques pour que son nasillard et qui
parlent déjà cette année un grand nombre
de terroristes islamistes qui vont être
libérés
car il faut bien voir que les gens qui
ont commencé à être mis en prison qui
ont écopé de 20 ans font dix ans de plus
en vous disant sorte là donc on sait
qu'à un moment on va appliquer la
liberté à des ennemis ne vont pas mieux
les avoir sous la main ici dans des
prisons plutôt que potentiellement les
hiboux et là bas c'est comme si on parle
oui mais c'est ce qu'on a déjà qu'on a
commencé à le faire le problème c'est
qu'on est en train de lâcher les kurdes
la vérité est là on est en train de
lâcher les kurdes sans abri vont se
faire massacrer par les turcs et donc
les tuent les kurdes ou dix bateaux des
bo gars vous êtes en train de nous
lâcher vous allez vous les reprendre
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu plus
compliqué c'est que c'est un élément
utilisé par les kurdes que nous lâchons
et donc on préfère lâcher les kurdes qui
vont se faire écrabouiller par les turcs
et pays risquant bien ici n'en
reviennent pas sortiront-ils mais là
parce que le point c'est qu'on
n'arrivera rien prouver parce qu'elle
n'aura pas les éléments d'un dossier
c'est tout dawkins auront gens tous les
jours on leur donne en avisant et pour
sortir au bout de cinq ans tout un
terrain parce que là-bas pour le bien de
la mort là-bas pour eux c'est la balle
sur la question c'est qu'est ce que
ferait les frais les turcs crs que les
kurdes les remettrait dans leur liberté
est ce que il est dur et dans les
prisons est-ce que les turcs arrivant
les relâcherait où les jugerait ça
c'était encore deviendrait une arme
d'entre eux deux périco légasse et
alexis de dire en fait savoir qu'ils
sont tués sur place
tenez ça arrangerait tout le monde c'est
une évidence et moi si on tient de mes
enfants et que
mes copains va tuer celui qui a tué mes
enfants ça m'arrange aussi l'application
pas de savoir ce qui arrange ou ce qui
arrange pas la question de savoir si on
respecte des principes du droit même
dans des situations extrêmes et
heureusement on l'a toujours fait ça
presque toujours fait ça le souvent fait
ça dans notre histoire et plus elles
progressent plus ont fait et quand on a
caen des collabos qui avait du sang sur
la main ou qui avait avoué des gosses à
l'extermination échapper aux
condamnations leoz épuration d'ailleurs
parfois abusif de la libération est bas
au bout de quelques années ils ont fini
par être libéré et ses axes terreur il
n'y a pas et il n'y a pas de raison de
bousculer tous nos principes alors après
il y adhérer des problèmes pratiques en
effet réel quand les terroristes sont en
fin de peine ne vois pas au nom de quoi
on ne libérait pas mais si on les libère
il faut évacuer évaluer à quel point il
reste ou pas radicaliser les surveiller
on l'a vu ces dernières années tout ceux
qui sont actuellement détenues la
déradicalisation tel qu'on l'a appelée
politique n'a pas vraiment est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il faut les fusillés sur
place non mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui surveille bourgeoisie oui
mais on va pas faire les mêmes
saloperies que les autres c'est la
personne c'est pas parce que tu iras
tour de bras que de nous retirer a
toujours quoi que ce soit le prix qu'ils
soient jugés et sanctionnés tels que le
droit de ce pays le prévoit
je préférais effectivement qu'il soit
jugé sur place on comprend qu'on doit
encore tout faire pour qu'il soit jugé
son place et est condamnée sur place je
pense que c'est la meilleure solution
la solution qui est présenté par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui est une
solution de dernier recours si vraiment
on n'est pas capable de 2,2
d'éviter moi ce que je trouve ces
impositions de castanet remet pas faite
au nom des principes que j'évoque les
faits non au nom de la répression
nécessaire qui risque de ne pas exercer
ce qui n'est pas exactement parler d'eux
oui mais les heureusement olivier
duhamel les deux ne sont pas forcément
contraint forcément pour en faire des
héros de banlieue qui seront en prison
en france
non merci alors on va regarder un petit
peu les commentaires de nos internautes
j -h me dit si un djihadiste est
condamnée dans un pays il doit purger sa
peine dans le pays où il est condamné
nicole complète en france ils seront
peut-être jugé ce renouveau libre
brownie tôt les traite son sens est jugé
par le pays qu'ils ont trahi dont ils
sont ressortissants
vrai ou faux sur le côté finalement ils
relèvent de la justice du pays qu'ils
ont trahi les volets dont 2 il relève
des deux îles on peut faire de la grèce
qui doit frapper aussi et le terrorisme
a été commanditée à partir de ces zones
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué de
savoir si l'étendue de leur méfait s'est
d'abord exclusivement au moyen orient ou
si c'est aussi chez nous alors on est
dans une situation je traiterai très
mouvante très instable très difficile il
faut simplement qu'ils soient sévèrement
eux conservés d'abord regardé faut
éviter leur fuite et qu'ils soient jugés
et moi évidemment tout ce qui permettra
de les juger sur place est bien
préférable à un rapatriement en france
avec toutes les conséquences que cela
peut avoir des référés dans ce que je
connais bien c'était les prisonniers
politiques de t1 et bien il puis il
purgeait en france leur condamnation
française et la police française les
agressions impérialistes espagnol willy
il avait un procès une autre peine il y
avait bien la double pénalité sur la
question qu'on vous posez sur twitter la
france doit-elle rapatrier les jets 10
français vous êtes une écrasante
majorité à penser que non 20 91 %
ça doit se régler au niveau européen
jean louis bourlanges parce que on parle
des français mais aussi des belges et
aussi d'autres nationalités d'autres
ressortissants
quantum est une solution c'est une
extension du problème l'extension du
domaine de la lutte comme dirait l'autre
c'est on a exactement les problèmes
similaires dans d'autres pays
est ce qu'on doit dégager une position
commune oui ça serait sans doute
préférable mais
chacun doit gérer effectivement sont ces
contingents les belges
je ne sais pas ce que vont faire les
belges sont grises ont effectivement pas
mal pas mal de gens à traiter ça serait
quand même un peu mieux qu'une fois au
moins les européens essaient d'avoir une
position relativement harmonisée elle a
l'air d'en douter
autant c'est indispensable construire on
y rêve d'ailleurs pas une politique
commune de l'asile de protection des
frontières etc
autant ne pas laisser chaque état
décider comment il traitera de ce
problème et tu vois je suis j'ai pas dit
je suis une formation pour les positions
communes mais qu'elle est absolument
contraire à celle que souhaitent les
français ou à celle que souhaitent les
italiens dans ce sens sont des domaines
dans lesquels la décision européenne
n'est pas un plus évident c'est un plus
évident d'avoir une politique européenne
des frontières c'est un plus évident si
on arrivait à construire une politique
de l'asile et c'est tard mais là c'est
pas un plus évident est donc ça va
apporter les souverainetés les
sensibilités nationales pour rien nous
explique qu'il faut les faire revenir au
nom des principes européens
oui oui non ça finira comme ça ça se
passe oui monsieur m'a fait comprendre
que je suis pas nous dit qu'il fallait
imposer au volant j'ai dit que ça serait
quand même mieux qu'on ait une approche
à peu près à peu près convergentes les
uns et les autres il faut imposer à qui
que ce soit quoi que ce soit non et ça
relève de la souveraineté non mais quand
même le sujet sous lesquels passent mais
d'accord mais ça fera quand même un peu
des gens que les 1 face à les autres
autrement semaine
merci monsieur dernière réaction nous
avons folman qui nous dit les services
secrets devraient s'occuper de la
neutralisation définitive de ces
individus les anglais le font déjà nous
on l'a fait aussi
et avec les mêmes failles elle plane
opérations ciblées de deux d'élimination
physique da semble de djihadistes et le
notamment tous ceux qui ont été
impliqués dans les assassinats en
dauphin de décapitations et c'est après
ben on n'a pas tué tout le monde donc la
question c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de
cela moi je pense qu'il faut surtout pas
qu'ils rentrent sur le territoire mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas si simple parce
que s'ils sont dans la nature qui
fichent le camp
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aussi débat que je
me mette définitivement à dos les 9 % de
vos téléspectateurs qui ne sont pas
encore je me permettrais de dire que
bien que ne connaissant pas le dossier
aussi bien que manifestement péricaud et
alexis je pense qu'il ya jihadistes et
djihadistes je pense qu'il ya des
djihadistes qui ont du sang sur les
mains et les autres pages penses tu en
as kino sont des tortionnaires et des
barbares absolue et d'autres ont laissé
embringuer la dent qui ont voulu
repartir qui ont pas réussi qu'on peut
pas mettre le catégorique jihadistes et
dire toute personne qui est parti là bas
on n'a qu'à dire à vos services secrets
d'aller les éliminer c'est tout on peut
pas et donc si on peut rire mais c'est
probable oui pour mir qui en a aucun il
faudra que les centrales ont préjugé
très élevé non ne pas le savoir mais en
même temps il ya un moment où peut-être
qu'il faut appliquer un peu sorte de
principe de précaution pour protéger nos
collègues concitoyens cycle de
précaution c'est pas donné mais je me
dis pas les ressources et la prédation
absolue c'est pas contre le principe de
précaution c'est de dire qu'il ne
remette plus les pieds sur le pays
répondait à ce qu'ils soient les secrets
et les éliminer voilà le principe de
précaution pourquoi pas non didier six
ont rapatrié l'un d'entre eux parce
qu'on n'est pas sûr de son engagement
intégristes et que cet homme venait à
commettre un crime ensuite en france
vous seriez bien embêté donc je
préférais plus je pense qu'on ait tué
tout le monde en sort de services
secondes et n'a pas encore dit toujours
la vérité c'est qu'il n'y a aucune bonne
solution a aucune bonne solution c'est
extrêmement difficile ici reste s'ils
risquent de s'évaporer
s'il reste il risque d'être jugé dans
des conditions mais wanda psion l'équipe
tous ont commettra d d d abomination
si on les fait rentrer tous ça pèsera
sont ou étaient un allemand et
effectivement ils seront à terme libérer
donc nous sommes c'est la politique gars
fort disert politique ne consiste pas à
résoudre
bien vivre avec des problèmes
souhaiterait que les kurdes et élimine
pour nous débarrasser du péché mort à
new delhi des nouvelles absolument vous
savez que vous ayez maison où il a une
double ce jeu là et donc de faire le
sale boulot à notre place
oui c'est je crois que c'est exactement
le dilemme moral qui est celui jeu
politique selon en pleine thermiques
chez sur ce sujet alors vraiment avant
et puis on passe à un autre sujet non
mais vraiment aron dans une sélection de
citations de raymond aron dans votre
journal le figaro d'hier ou d'avant-hier
la vérité qui m'est le plus désagréable
et de reconnaître les sens maquillage
vielen de la machiavélienne de la
politique en détestant cette essence
comment il aida du pape avant le
massacre de bézy redoux sang neuf à la
reconnaîtra les siens
rappel historique vous propose de parler
de notre deuxième sujet celui des
européennes de la liste
lr la commission nationale d'investiture
doit valider aujourd'hui le trio choisi
par laurent wauquiez pour mener cette
liste trois nombreux ces trois profils
pour un savant dosage politique au sein
de l air on en parle tout de suite mais
d'abord de réaction celle de christian
estrosi qui malgré son étiquette les
républicains ne manque pas une occasion